der angriffskrieg putins in der ukraine
einige zehntausend haushalte das war
mitdiskutieren zu nahe treten zu wollen
hat ja auch für deutschland unmittelbare
sind diese u bahn so ausgestaltet dass
gerade vor zwei jahren und dann zeigt es
dass wir vielleicht auch etwas panik
sie auch schutz bieten können dass man
folgen und wir haben gemerkt dass wir in
sich eben dass ganz viele dinge nicht
gerade schön also panik ist nie ein
also schutz tore beispielsweise dort
mehr funktionieren das denkt bei der
deutschland ein riesiges problem haben
kommunikation an das fängt bei geht bei
guter ratgeber in der politik finde man
einsetzen kann und das dritte was glaube
beim bevölkerungsschutz es hat ein
muss es mit heißem herzen betreiben aber
ich sehr wichtig ist dass wir auch die
wärme weiter und wenn so was im winter
schlaglicht geworfen darauf dass wir
individuelle schutz infrastruktur uns
kühlen kopf trotzdem ist natürlich die
passiert und alte menschen
nicht mal die grundlegenden sicherheiten
anschauen da gab es früher in der
beispielsweise mit so einer lage
analyse völlig richtig wir haben
konfrontiert sind da braucht man dann
unserer bevölkerung bieten können und
bauordnung beispielsweise vorgaben das
jahrelang von der friedensdividende
entsprechende möglichkeiten und
das ist ein erhebliches problem ist sind
in den kellern entsprechende
profitiert weil wir eben die mittel die
entsprechende kräfte die dann auch
vorkehrungen getroffen werden mussten
viele szenarien plötzlich in den blick
wir nicht für katastrophenschutz nicht
unterstützen können und das was man
damit wenigstens die hausbewohner sich
gerückt lieber vorher vor dem
für militärische ausbildung und
auch direkt in sicherheit bringen können
glaube ich naheliegenderweise fordern
angriffskrieg gar nicht betrachtet haben
ausstattung
muss ist dass wir für solche szenarien
in einem geschützten raum auch über so
nutzen mussten an andere dinge
insbesondere blackouts angriffe oder
wenn es mal großflächiger werden sollte
was müssen wir jetzt wieder nachdenken
investieren müssen aber wir müssen
das ist ganz ganz wichtig wenn wir über
dann auch residente stützpunkte vorsehen
einfach auch selbstkritisch ausgeben wir
auch entsprechende sabotageakte all das
das thema schutzräumen reden was für
waren naiv an vielen stellen das
mich macht sowas eigentlich sprachlos
bedeutet nicht dass wir jetzt
die beispielsweise in den bezirken oder
sind szenarien die plötzlich jetzt ins
wütend fassungslos was auch immer wir
möglicherweise am morgen in einer
in den gemeinden auch dann funktionieren
blickfeld gerückt sind und obwohl wir in
gleichen lage sind wie die ukraine heute
reden jetzt über die folgen von
wenn der strom oder wenn das gas- oder
aber wissen es nicht ich kann es nicht
den letzten jahren schon gemerkt haben
politischen entscheidungen der letzten
ähnliche dinge ausfallen warum auch
zehn zwanzig dreißig jahre wo es immer
dass viele dinge bei uns in der
beantworten ich glaube niemand auf der
immer da brauchen wir lösungen
infrastruktur nicht funktionieren das
welt kann es sicher beantworten und
hieß ja wir sind ja von freunden umgeben
alexanders selbst persönlich angst wenn
deswegen müssen wir als politik auch
fängt bei der alarmierung an sirenen
die nato schützt und die amerikaner
eine kluge ablegung da treffen wir
du so etwas
sind nicht vorhanden ich habe heute
naja angst ich bin wie gesagt setzt über
müssen sozusagen schutz auf der einen
haben und traurig die franzosen haben
gerade in der berliner presse gelesen
atomwaffe man hat wirklich gedacht man
seite sicherstellt und gewährleisten
beispielsweise von den 400 serien die
diesen abgrund an professionalität dass
ohne aber sozusagen in panik zu
lebt in so einem europa lummerland und
wir immer hören wir müssen in szenarien
wir in berlin bräuchten sind
verfallen so und deswegen glaube ich
mittlerweile zwei installiert worden da
arbeiten ob diese pandemien sind
das finde ich einfach ein furchtbares
muss man aber den blick und auch ein
umweltkatastrophen kriegs den namen wir
bisschen weiter steht es geht ja nicht
versagen der der der politische
kann man eigentlich nur noch mit dem
alleine nur um schutzräume und bunker
müssen nachhaltig denken und dann fällt
entscheidungsträger der vergangenen
kopf schütteln es sind viele dinge die
sondern wir haben ja etwa bei der
jahrzehnte da kann sich ja keine partei
man offenbar aus denen den schönsten
uns fehlen die widerstandsfähigkeit
flutkatastrophe im aartal gesehen dass
aus nehmen die in
träumen der guten denkungsart durch
regierungsverantwortung war das immer
unserer infrastruktur ist nicht
es selbst bei so einem fundamentalen
ausreichend und wir haben seit 2007 alle
gesagt hat ja den schaden vom deutschen
einen krieg mit dem in der tat keiner
sachen wie warnsystem das ist der hammer
gerechnet hat der uns aber doch ein
schutzräume abgebaut in deutschland 2007
volk abwenden den schutz mehreren das
prozess nicht erst auf drängen mussten
wir hatten jetzt vor einigen jahren ja
hat jeder minister geschworen und dann
wir doch schon lange haben müssen also
das muss man sich vorstellen wir sind
einen bundesweiten warmen tag wo man
sagten allerdings naja aber irgendwelche
natürlich habe ich auch angst oder sorge
jahrzehntelang jetzt sehr gut mit dieser
schlimme katastrophen die werden schon
einmal katastrophenfälle durch spielen
mich wenn ich höre jeder soll jetzt auf
friedensdividende gefahren wir haben uns
nicht kommen und wenn dann reicht es
wollte um einfach mal die bevölkerung
irgendwie dass wir uns auf ausländische
darauf verlassen auf diese
einmal darauf achten dass er genügend
auch daran zu gewöhnen was passiert
friedensdividende jetzt müssen wir
wasser zu hause hat kauft ihr ein
hilfe verlassen oder dass wir irgendwie
eigentlich müsst ihr euch verhalten das
das ganze gewissermaßen gesundbeten
gaskocher wollte mir jetzt empfohlen ich
realisieren das war eine trügerische
ist katastrophal in die hose gegangen
sicherheit und deswegen ist es ganz
hörte hörig wir haben keine einzige
habe noch kein ich muss schauen wo ich
weil einfach die systeme völlig
sirene in berlin keine einzige in berlin
den hier bekomme ich habe geguckt wie
wichtig dass wir jetzt umsteuern jetzt
überlastet waren so und ich glaube da
lange hält dennoch meine meine dosen
wir können also knapp 3000 leute
entsprechende aktionen einleiten wir
müsste man schon schlüsse draus ziehen
gesamtdeutsch sind momentan nur mit
besorgen das wusste ich alles nicht muss
brauchen eine schonungslose
und dann muss man einfach ganz
bestandsaufnahme und dann müssen wir
selbstkritisch sagen da ist in den
katastrophenschutz plätzen versorgen das
ich sagen hätte ich mich früher
letzten jahren einfach dann zu wenig
dafür sorgen dass wir dort wieder tritt
informieren sollen ja aber es wurde auch
heißt wir schauen wir zurück auf
jahrzehnte versagen der
passieren viele dinge sind in den länder
nie vermittelt dass das wichtig ist dass
fassen er zu einer ganz praktische frage
verantwortung aber natürlich muss der
sicherheitspolitik wenn man wirklich
man sich selber drum kümmern soll und
bund auch sein teil dazu trage neben der
dachte alles um uns herum sind lieb alle
der vom staat fühle ich mich wirklich
sich mehr als bürgerin direkt aufsteigen
cs oder absolut ich werde deswegen muss
allein gelassen der stelle also ich bin
sind nett und die größten probleme die
brauchen wir mehr bunker bunker sind
man selbstkritisch sich an die eigene
wir haben sind vielleicht bei die mass
nase auf was man falsch gemeinde herz
ich muss leider nur ehrlich sagen dass
index und waldsterben aber ich stimme
natürlich etwas das man nicht von heute
und warum haben wir diese lage jetzt
ich auch betroffen war von dieser
auf morgen herstellen kann wir haben
ich stimme ihnen natürlich zu aber wer
geld ist ja genug da ist die tasten der
naivität ich muss sagen also ich war
alle schutzräume wie gesagt wieder
hätte denn vor fünf jahren oder vor drei
ist nicht ganz klein wieso stehen wir so
naiv ja gut aber ich glaube es ist immer
privatisiert es gibt keine mehr die zur
jahren oder noch letztes jahr in ein vor
einfach mit finger zu zeigen sagt jetzt
schlecht dar warum haben wir keinen
verfügung stehen wir haben auch keine
funktionieren katastrophenschutz es ist
gesellschaft naiv also vor einer feier
corona wirklich gedacht dass wir von
eine frage der priorisierung gewesen das
möglichkeiten die von heute auf morgen
vor einem halben jahr hat mich mein sohn
existenziellen krisen heißt muss man
wieder in betrieb zu nehmen das was man
muss man so sagen also ich denke das ist
gefragt als ich ihm gesagt er solle zum
auch denken ja aber ehrlich ehrlich wer
auch richtig wenn man sagt da ist nicht
jetzt ins auge fassen muss in drei dinge
der eine schuld oder der andere die
marine gehen er sein abitur hinter sich
hätte gedacht dass wir einen
erstens diese bunker sozusagen wieder
ganze politik hat da versagt das ist
gebracht und ich habe gesagt ich war bei
konventionellen krieg mit bodentruppen
flott zu machen und auch aktiv zu
der marine hat geht auch zur marine und
ganz klar es sind aber jetzt gar nicht
hat er mich irgendwann mal gefragt ist
vor unserer tür haben ich habe nicht mit
schalten das zweite ist dass wir uns
so die kriegerischen szenarien oder auch
das denn gefährlicher natürlich
so was muss da ein katastrophenschutzamt
anschauen müssen was haben wir an schutz
die die wirklichen sag ich mal
berechtigte frage ich habe den vom
geben es muss katastrophenschutzpläne
infrastruktur brauchen wie der biograf
flutkatastrophen es gibt auch ganz ganz
halben jahr ausgelacht hab gesagt marine
geben das erwarte ich einfach als bürger
wir brauchen schutzräume aus
einfache dinge beispielsweise wenn der
das war bei mir freizeitbeschäftigung
der steuerzahler dass es leute gibt die
strom ausfällt ja da lacht jeder drüber
ist mir da sind wir natürlich mit der
sich dadurch natürlich eine frage kurzer
naheliegenden gründen es kann immer
sich sehen wie sie wir trinken und
wenn der strom ausfällt auch wenn der
check stellen darf wenn männer sich
etwas passieren und werden wir dann
strom länger ausfallen dann haben wir
jugendlich stockholm gelaufen das war
nicht geschützt ist der hat ein problem
jetzt hier so anhört hat man das gefühl
nachdem er ein paar übungen gemacht
ein existenzielles problem wir hatten
wer solchen schutz nicht hat aber viel
ist schon schlimmer als damals im kalten
das beispielsweise in berlin wo für 31
haben auf hoher see das war vom staat
krieg wir brauchen schutzräume wie
wichtiger glaube ich ist dass wir uns
bezahlt der urlaub ehrlich gesagt wir
anschauen was haben wir für
stunden der strom gefallen ist für
gefährlich ist denn die lage oder könnte
möglichkeiten in den städten haben wir
haben das war die bundeswehr hat runden
beispielsweise um in kiew zum beispiel
man auch sagen ohne meinen
gebaut und hat aber der lgbt parade mit
gemacht also es war es war es war also
ernsthaft er konnte ich mich vor einem
halben jahr die frage meines sohnes ist
es gefährlich zu bundesmarine zu gehen
habe ich aus vollem herzen gesagt
absolut nicht und jetzt wm dritter am
vierten juli hat er sein antritt wird
auf die fregatte bayern irgendwann
kommen und die fregatte bayern wird
womöglich im in der ostsee in der ostsee
unterwegs sein und da kannst du mir
kannst du gewinnen nach der neuen lage
muss ich die fragen ganz ganz neu
beantworten ist es denn gefährlich für
meinen sohn auf einen auf einer fregatte
der bundesmarine durch die ostsee zu
fahren aber wie gesagt vor einem halben
jahr habe ich da hab ich über diese
frage gelacht ich finde nur dass du eine
gewisse ehrlichkeit und auch annehmen
müssen oder oder uns zugestehen müssen
dass wir als gesellschaft so lange in
frieden gelebt haben das ist eigentlich
die vorstellung einer action for corona
ich mich rechnet corona ein als corona
kam und ich und wir plötzlich sozusagen
nicht wussten befinden wir uns plötzlich
in der zombie apocalypse ich habe das
damals schon als als historische zäsur
gefunden ich habe noch gesagt ich habe
in meiner lebenszeit ich bin 1969
geboren die sonne so eine existenzielle
bedrohung erlebt das mir gesagt wird du
darfst ein haus nicht verlassen deshalb
waren wir nach dem atomschlag plötzlich
hat sich daraus geht das ist vielleicht
alles nicht gar nicht so schlimm aber am
anfang mussten wir in der redaktion
wurde gefragt wer möchte dann nach
italien reisen ich habe mich freiwillig
gemeldet ich wollte ich wollte endlich
das leere venedig sehen aber ich sag
euch wir hatten die diese dieses gefühl
eine existenzielle krise kommt das habe
ich seit meiner lebenszeit nicht erlebt
also in meiner zeit ebenso seit ich
politisch denken kann seit anfang der
80er jahre waren wir im absoluten
frieden und die vorstellung schutzbunker
zu brauchen oder dosen zu halten war
absolut aber alles in allem wenn die
geschichte schauen ist frieden die
ausnahme das müssen wir zur kenntnis
nehmen es ist uns nicht geschenkt worden
unser leben in frieden zu beginnen und
im leben zu beenden in frieden zu
beenden muss man ganz klar sagen schön
dass wir den frieden haben tun wir alles
was wir uns erhalten oder zurückgewinnen
aber er ist die ausnahme